cru cuit en fait rien dans ce moule ou
tapioca le yucca appelé aussi maniaque
est à découvrir
compte en commun cette crème brésilienne
se tait aux perles ce gâteau philippins
et le pudding au tapioca le manioc cette
grosse racine fait partie des plantes
les plus consommé au monde on l'appelle
aussi yucca en espagnol ou en anglais
que ça va et vous vous l'appelez comment
banjjak banjjak banjjak
à sait cultiver partout au pays au
brésil luiz a commencé aux nombreuses et
passaient plus chaud tout comme le
manioc la cheffe diana santos est
originaire du brésil elle connaît bien
les marchés publics là bas ou le manioc
est roi au québec depuis 10 ans et les
propriétaire du resto traiteurs bouchers
brésil à saint-eustache c'est le
portugais et après 1607 commencé à
porter à d autres régions dont coeur
elle l europe afrique qui me sert
vraiment brésilienne a lancé mme
désilets
tout parle de salles c'est ça le manioc
oui c'est ça la vrai maniaque diana
utilise le manioc ou mandioka sous
toutes ses formes dont le tapioca qui
est en fait la fécule de manioc réseau
contre de tapioca va penser justement à
les crêpes à taïwan on pense plutôt hot
et opère le fait de tapioca apparu dans
les années 80 il est maintenant
populaire partout dans le monde
l'explosion du nombre de boutiques de
bois brut et le démontre
c'est une boisson en même temps un
dessert dans un vin
les philippins eux font le fameux kassav
à cake ce gâteau traditionnel est fait à
base de manioc rap et de lait de coco et
de les concentrer avec une couche de
crème pâtissière sur le dessus le
restaurant junior à montréal l'offre
fièrement dans son menu et leur touche
finale pour faire fondre le fromage est
plutôt l'emploi ya toutes les manières
place un serment à nous ça s'est
vraiment c'est un produit qui est les
plus consommés en afrique je dirais oui
moi c'est quelque chose que je suis né
dans ça je pense que je prenais déjà des
bouillies des manières qu'acheter petit
puis je continue à les consommer jusqu'à
maintenant selon ge petit originaire de
la république démocratique du congo est
aussi une adepte du légume racine il
s'apprête comme l'est le le pomme de
terre mais lui est quand même plus
corsée ya vraiment un petit coup la
pomme de terre est fade hausse à goûte
rien comparativement manioc manioc tu
les gouttes ici c'est le restaurant mais
juste à côté vous avez aussi un autre
commerce ou à l'épicerie ici vous en
avez toujours du frais oui on a toujours
du serait selon ge offre des produits
dérivés à son épicerie il ya solo farine
feuilles bâton de manioc fermenté
plusieurs produits qui accompagne très
bien les plats dombasle manger toujours
avec des choses tout ça et puis
immanente sas à remplir
très riche en glucides le manioc procure
un effet rassasiant il est à la fois
très digeste il peut remplacer les
féculents sans gluten et serial plus
traditionnelle à nos plats les plus
populaires et des check et qui est
vraiment le plein d'un soleil de la côte
d'ivoire d'ailleurs que le couscous de
manioc dans son restaurant seul en
cuisine la tchéquie pour accompagner ces
plats
il ya des tchèques et déjà congelés qui
est préparé en côte d'ivoire et sa
vessie congé quand savoir des jeunes et
ça va faire comme le couscous exactement
il devient grand ni deux et puis on peut
les consommer en boîte
un autre accompagnement pour les plats
d'une maquiller sous l'eau le manioc aux
frites il faut les pêcher tout juste mal
est coupée faire bouillir la clé c'est
de faire bouillir un petit peu
légèrement ensuite les frire cimelli
trop sec il reste croustillant à
l'extérieur et clignon à l'intérieur
comme ça on veut le goûter c'est
l'adopter
notre chef brésilienne nous a préparé
des crêpes de tapioca au brésil ça
s'appelle et pau ville où il ya les
sucres et il allait plus accès du ou
donner des textures différentes de
certains allemands ça dépend la dignité
qu'on va mettre bas et grattez la farine
des tapis au cas les scellés tapioca
dans l'eau pendant banque a trait au
frigo ensuite passé ou délits pour
n'avoir que les féculent donc c'est très
facile
diana ajoute un peu de noix de coco et
du sirop d'érable pour la version salée
et l'utilisent une viande sèche et un
fromage cheddar
légèrement sucré oui mais c'est la
texture qui est intéressante exactions
parce que c'est comme cole et j'essaie
de trouver une équivalence c'est le
concombre accès fécule et quelque chose
de voyance en serre que leur béret ouais
c'est ça de tout petit bilan
légèrement semaine à gagner que va
donner un goût latapie toxicomanes base
[Musique]
c'est quoi les pentes de 15 ou des pains
au fromage se fait avec la base des
faillites d'états piot que mélangée avec
du lait des oeufs et fromages du bon son
chat d'oc 100g capable toujours toute ma
vie je mange que savez vous préférez
donc et rien de plus brésilienne sauf
finalement non c'est vraiment besoin
[Musique]